In lecture, we said the number of rabbits in a given month was = to
the number of rabbits the previous month + the number of rabbits 2 months ago.
In the new model, we have the same number of growth of rabbits,
but instead we're going to subtract the number of rabbits that are 5 months old
to account for them dying.
Astute readers will know that this doesn't actually model death correctly of rabbits,
but it's a good example for coding a recursive function.
So with this in mind, let's get to the programming.
So the first thing I've done is at our base case,
which was defined in the problem statement.
And if it's not the base case, we're just going to plug in the formula
that we got from the problem statement.
So this may look like it's finished, but there's one issue,
and that is, what we'd do and say n = 3, when 3 - 5 is a negative number,
and we don't have anything to account for that.
We're just going to continue forever, basically,
because we're never going to hit the base case of 1 or 2.
So we need to actually add a second base case.
And our second base case, basically, says if we had a number that's not 1 or 2,
or below a 1 or 2, then we're going to return 0 and not effect the count
of the number of rabbits alive for that month.